let's try the 804 area code who's
calling today from 804 hey David this is
Jarrett forgiveme time how you doing can
you hear me
yes yes good so I saw your video
yesterday about William Boris someone
and I see that you believe William but
somebody on the Mueller report is shady
so I want to ask what do you expect me
allure to come out and and say he's
being dishonest nope and you know why
because molar already punted to William
bar on the issue of obstruction which
makes no sense to me I we already
learned that molar narrowed the scope of
the investigation extraordinarily
despite the fact that we heard from the
right and Trump all the time that molar
is investigating too broadly if we trust
bars summary the investigation was
actually much more narrow
I think molar simply wants out of the
spotlight molar feels that he's done we
don't know what Matthew Whitaker's role
was or was not within that in the
conversations that he had with Robert
Miller to the extent we know about them
so no I don't think that it's reasonable
molar has not said anything this entire
time to suggest that he is now going to
come out with some kind of attack on
William bar summary I don't think it's
reasonable to expect okay I think that
is pretty clear I'll let me add on to
that YUM
so they said where they're gonna release
it in two weeks not months apparently
what do you think the objective is to do
for that reason they try and blow off
steam well the statement what Lindsey
Graham Republican senators said earlier
this week that he was told by William
Barr is that it's going to take a few
weeks rather than a few months for
Donald Trump to decide what he wants
redacted from the investigation into him
which is insane by the way so I don't
know that there's that much strategy
behind weeks rather than months I think
it's just that's how long they've
determined Trump's lawyers want to go
through the report okay that's
interesting appreciate that David okay
no problem thank you for the call
and we don't know the I mean some of
those questions are speculative we don't
exactly know why we're presuming that's
that's how long they need to go
the report